>>> THIS MORNING IN OUR "SPRING
INTO SUMMER" SERIES, WHAT TO
EXPECT THIS SUMMER AS LIFE
STARTS TO RETURN TO NORMAL.
ONE WAY TO EASE BACK INTO
TRAVELING IS TO FIND A VACATION
SPOT WITH A LITTLE MORE SPACE
LIKE A VISIT TO ONE OF AMERICA'S
63 NATIONAL PARKS.
WE SENT JONATHAN VIGLIOTTI TO
CALIFORNIA'S YOSEMITE NATIONAL
PARK WHICH IS MY FAVORITE.
>> Reporter: WE'RE HERE AT
TUNNEL VIEW, AND YOU CAN CLEARLY
SEE HOW YOSEMITE BECAME THE MUSE
FOR FAMED PHOTOGRAPHER AN SELL
ADAMS.
THIS PARK HAS EVERYTHING FROM
DRAMATIC WATERFALLS TO TOWERING
SEQUOIAS, AN EL CAPTAIN AND HALF
DOME.
DURING THE PANDEMIC NATIONAL
PARKS WELCOMED ROUGHLY 237
MILLION VISITORS, A 30% DROP
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE EXPECTED TO GO
BACK UP.
YOSEMITE PREPARING FOR UP TO
THREE MILLION PEOPLE.
PARK RANGERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE CONSTANTLY ADAPTING TO LOCAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS, SO MAKE SURE
YOU CHECK THE RULES AT EACH
PARK.
BEFORE YOU PACK A TENT FOR
YOSEMITE, MAKE A RESERVATION.
THIS SUMMER IT'S REQUIRED HERE
NOT JUST FOR CAMPING BUT EVEN IF
YOU'RE GOING TO VISIT FOR THE
DAY.
ALL PART OF AN EFFORT TO CONTROL
CROWDS.
ONCE YOU'RE HERE, THERE'S PLENTY
TO SEE AND DO.
ALL OF THE TRAILS ARE OPEN,
INCLUDING THE ONE HERE AT
YOSEMITE FALLS.
REMEMBER TO KEEP YOUR DISTANCE.
BECAUSE OF SOCIAL DISTANCING,
SOME PARKS LIKE YOSEMITE HAVE
CANCELED THEIR SHUTTLE SERVICES.
SO PEOPLE ARE ENCOURAGED TO
BRING OR RENT A BIKE TO GET
AROUND.
YOU MAY ALSO WANT TO PICK UP A
KAYAK AT YOUR LOCAL SPORTING
GOODS SHOP.
WHILE THIS YEAR'S EXPERIENCE IS
GOING TO FEEL A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT, THE BEAUTY OF OUR
NATIONAL PARKS REMAINS
UNRIVALED, AND THEY'RE A GREAT
PLACE TO TEST THE WATERS.
FO